hi everyone
i'm jay maria i'm a graduate student at
stanford university
and today i'm going to talk with you
about the following question
which is is the space complexity of
planted clique recovery the same as that
of detection
now there might be words out there that
in there that are unfamiliar to some of
you
don't worry about it we'll get there
together
but before we get there we need to look
at a slightly different question first
and this question is what is a tractable
inference problem
if you ask a statistician this the
statistician the statistician will say
to you
well if you can extract some sort of
signal
from the input uh despite that random
noise that might be present
then it's tractable okay that's great
if you ask the same question to a
computer scientist you might hear
well if there's an efficient algorithm
to solve the problem
then it is tractable okay
so you have two different notions of
tractability
and we're not sure whether they coincide
or not
be great if they do however this sort of
problem has been studied a lot in the
past few decades
and the consensus that has built up is
that these two notions do not coincide
in fact for several problems like
planted clique sparse pca
tensor pca people have
come up with ways of predicting and
understanding
when uh computationally efficient
algorithms exist
and it turns out that there is a gap
between
where statistics says things work and
where
computer scientists say things work so
far i've given you a fairly abstract
view of this sort of misalignment
between these two notions so let's look
at a concrete example to make things
clearer let's look at the plant at
league problem
and this problem is basically one where
there's a plantedly graph what is this
there's a random graph
on n vertices and there's a subset of
vertices of size k
which is picked uniformly at random and
a clique is added on to that subset of
vertices
i don't need you to remember the details
of this problem too much
all i need you to understand is that
there are n vertices
uh there is a parameter k which ranges
from 1 to n
which you want to think of as a signal
to noise parameter signal to noise ratio
and there are two variants of this
problem the first
is called detection in this variant
you're either given a completely random
graph or you're given a plant early
graph
you don't know which one then you have
to figure out which one you want to
detect whether or not a clique has been
planted in the graph that you've been
given
the second variant which is formally at
least as hard as the first one
is the recovery variant where you've
been given a planetary graph and you
need to find the subset
of vertices on which a clique has been
plotted
okay that's good
[Music]
it may not be obvious but it is true
that as k increases
the problem becomes easier in fact
a statistician would tell you that if k
is larger than 2 log n
then this problem is solvable no problem
no issues
detection recovery both of them we can
do it
computer scientists uh started asking
well okay but are there efficient
algorithms to do this
it turns out that for
the the algorithm that sort of works
above
the statistical threshold of 2 log n is
not
efficient and all the
many polynomial time algorithms that
have been
sort of designed for this problem all
failed to solve it
below k equals square root n k is
order of square root n in fact people
have gone further and studied
classes of algorithms and like
convex hierarchies statistical query
algorithms
algorithms based on low degree
polynomials and shown that provably
all of these failed to give polynomial
time algorithms
for k smaller than this threshold
and what this has done it has cemented
the belief that there is an exponential
gap
between the clique sizes or the signal
to noise ratio
at which statistics says something is
tractable versus where
computational efficiency considerations
say something extractable
okay that's great i've given you one
concrete example of a problem where such
a gap exists and i've also told you that
this sort of gap exists
in many other problems but one thing
i've kind of swept under the rug is that
i didn't
formally tell you what we mean by
computational efficiency
and perhaps you've already understood
that what we meant here is a
computational efficient algorithm is one
that runs in polynomial time
and to you this might be an extremely
reasonable thing to do
we have decades of experience with
equating efficiency
with polynomial time algorithms and
even more important making this
identification here has led to
a very nice understanding of uh
statistical computational gaps or this
misalignment between these two notions
so much so that we even now have a bunch
of reduction based evidence for
hardness of different problems in this
sort of
way now
having said that computer scientists
do indeed study other notions of
efficiency
they study things like space complexity
or streaming complexity
or communication complexity these are
all useful in different contexts but
even more importantly they seem to have
insights
into situations where we would not have
expected them to have insights
space complexity turns out to
be useful in understanding the
complexity of two player games
communication complexity turns out to
have a
tremendous amount of use in
understanding the streaming of
a complexity of problems so what this
suggests is that even in the statistical
context of
statistical problems it might be useful
to consider
notions of efficiency other than simply
polynomial time algorithms
more importantly one could argue that
this study of statistical computational
gaps already implicitly does this
on the previous slide i gave you a bunch
of
restricted algorithmic classes that
people study
and get provable guarantees for
saying that no polynomial time algorithm
within this framework
can sort of solve the problem below a
certain
one could say that what they're doing is
studying
a non-standard notion of
resource or complexity for example it
could be the number of levels in a
convex hierarchy
or it could be the degree of polynomial
that we used to compute with
and a lot of the success in this
field has come from studying these
non-standard notions of complexity
although this is only implicit because
the lens with which people view these
results remains firmly that of
equating efficiency with polynomial
algorithms
what this suggests is that maybe we
should explicitly study alternate
notions of efficiency in the statistical
context and
maybe that might turn out to be
interesting
okay so suppose we agree that
we should study alternative efficiency
in this context
what is the first thing we should do
one could argue that the nicest thing
about uh
this study of statistical computational
gaps
has been the very fact that we can find
that they exist
uh we can find their locations and it
would be
would be kind of sad if if we change the
notion of efficiency we use
and suddenly these gaps disappeared or
maybe
more quantitatively speaking the
locations
at which these gaps appear changed too
much
we kind of what we're asking is are
these
gaps fundamental to the problem or do
they
depend very heavily on the notion of
computational efficiency we use
okay so this slide is kind of this
the stepping stone for the work we're
going to discuss today
these questions are very broad and
understandably hard to answer what the
work we're going to discuss
does is it it takes one step towards
trying to answer these problems by
looking at one specific problem and one
specific notion of complexity
and trying to see what happens when we
put them together
but by a stroke of luck
i have already introduced the problem
we're going to discuss the blanket
clique problem so i don't have to do it
again what we really care about now is
trying to study whether the space
complexity of the planetary problem
throws up the same sort of
statistical computational phenomena as
the polynomial time complexity
what were these phenomena well first we
saw that
the statistical computational gap
existed
second while we didn't see this uh
what is true is that this problem turns
out to have
a central place uh in the sort of
web of reductions that people use to
reason about equivalences between
different statistical problems and third
which i didn't stress but it turns out
that
there is a formal reduction between
these two problems
which makes the time complexity of
detection and recovery basically the
same at least
if we look at it in a coarse grained way
by saying that
the time complexity is the same if it is
uh within a polynomial factor of
each other and
ideally we want to say that uh if we
study the space complexity of the
problem
these phenomena also happen
we won't look at two that's a bit too
ambitious for this work
but what we will look at is points one
and three and hope that we can show that
these sorts of things also happen for
space complexity
okay so what is space complexity and
what is an efficient
algorithm well space complexity is
basically just trying to measure
how much memory or working space you
require to solve a problem think of it
like how much grass paper you need to
solve a complicated math problem
this is a very well studied notion of
complexity and it has
emerged that the correct notion of
efficient
space bounded algorithms is that is that
of logarithmic space algorithm so
you have logarithmically many bits in
the size of the input
and that lets you do a lot of nice
things
so this is the sort of benchmark we're
going to use
to understand what an efficient
algorithm is in this world
another reason to do this is that if
an algorithm works in logarithmic space
it also works in at most polynomial time
this means that the planetary conjecture
which is a conjecture that there are no
polynomial time algorithms below the
square root and
threshold for planet leaks immediately
sort of would imply that there are no
log space algorithms for these smaller
leaks either
okay um what are some
easy to see facts about the space
complexity of the bloody key problem
well it's actually quite easy to see
that
just above the statistical threshold we
can
use x already existing algorithms
that work in quasi-polynomial time and
just
analyze their space complexity and it
turns out they require
log square and widths of space that's
not efficient
uh so but it is the best we seem to be
able to do right now
and if the planetary conjecture is true
we also don't expect that
the complexity out there to go down to
logarithmic
number of bits for the detection version
of the problem
as soon as we're above the root n
threshold
we can actually solve this problem in
logarithmic space very easily
this is because just counting the number
of edges
in your graph gives a good
is a good test for whether
the graph has a planted leak of that
size or not
and counting the number of edges is
something we can easily do in log space
okay uh but this doesn't say anything
about
the recovery problem for large k
because uh the number of edges is not
it's not going to help us recover the
planetary it just tells us that one
exists
and so this is where
the question now becomes is the space
complexity of planet leak
recovery the same as that of detection
uh some of you might notice that this
was also the title of the dark
and why is this
important well if we can show that such
an algorithm exists
then the time complexity based stat comp
gap would also imply a space complexity
based gap
because the time complexity based gap
would imply there are no polynomial time
algorithms
and hence no logarithmic space
algorithms below the root and threshold
while above the root and threshold
we would have found a algorithm for for
a log space algorithm for recovery
this all this is already true for
detection but not necessarily true for
recovery as far as we know so far
the second thing this will show is that
the coarse grained complexity of
detection and recovery
are the same no matter what notion of
efficiency we use
space or time i won't go into
details of what exactly we mean by
coarse grained but
you can look at the paper
and what this would do is that it would
show that this threshold
signal to noise ratio or leak size of
square root n
is essentially something fundamental
about this problem
it's robust to changes in the notion of
efficiency
it's robust to changes in the
formulation of the problem whether we're
looking at detection or recovery
and that is why we want to show that a
log space algorithm
for planetary recovery exists for gay
above the square root and threshold
okay how might we go about doing this
well maybe previous
polynomial time algorithms can be
adapted
or maybe if we analyze their space
complexity
uh maybe we can implement them
efficiently so let's just take a look at
what
the previous literature says
one thing i've already mentioned to you
is that there is a
formal reduction between detection and
recovery
uh from alone at all in 2007
what they do is they give
and if there is an algorithm to solve
the detection problem they give an
algorithm to solve the recovery problem
if we can implement this reduction space
efficiently
then we should be done in fact we
can implement this reduction space
efficiently but unfortunately we're not
quite done
the catch is that the statistical
success of this reduction depends
on the sec on the failure probability of
the detection algorithm
being quite small little of one over n
and unfortunately the log space
detection algorithm that we have
does not have a failure probability that
small and so
this reduction idea does not quite work
okay why don't we actually look at the
polynomial algorithms that exist and see
if they can be implemented efficiently
well a spectral algorithm by alone
crivale which in pseudocurve was the
first
polynomial time algorithm that could
solve the
contract leak problem the recovery
problem for clicks above size
root n what
we need to do to use this algorithm is
to compute the
compute and eigenvector of the adjacency
matrix of the graph
this eigenvector obviously requires
polynomial
polynomial and n number of bits to
specify
so it's not clear how to
how to implement this space efficiently
or to compress this
eigenvector having said that
there could be hope for a spectral
algorithm
the eigenvalue corresponding to that
eigenvector
serves as a detection test
for for plant leaks and more importantly
it's the failure probability of the test
that uses the eigen value
is much smaller than little of one so
if we can compute that eigenvalue and
use the reduction from
alone at all then we'd be done
unfortunately
we do not know how to compute that
eigenvalue
to the desired accuracy in logarithmic
space
okay what next well
there are a bunch of optimization
theoretic semi-definite programs that
solve the planetary recovery problem
can we implement any of those space
efficiently
well unlikely
at the very least we know that there are
no generic
log space algorithms to solve
semi-definite programs
if we did then it turns out that
that every polynom every
every problem with the polynomial time
algorithm would have a log space
algorithm
and we do not believe this to be true
okay maybe let's look at the class of
combinatorial
linear time algorithms that have been
developed in the past decade or two
there is an algorithm by figer and ron
which
maintains a vertex subset
decreases it by one in every round by
one vertex in every round
and it sort of removes vertices that it
thinks are not in the planetary league
and eventually ends up with
essentially what is the plant clique
unfortunately for most of its run time
this algorithm has to maintain a
polynomially large
subset of the vertices which we can't do
in log space
and there does not seem to be any
realistic way of compressing
this set so that we can implement it
space efficiently
the algorithm of deshpande and montanari
sort of is a message passing algorithm
and it produces
a dense n cross n matrix
in every iteration clearly we can't do
this in log space
but there might be a space efficient
implementation of this message passing
algorithm
that sort of recomputes messages when
needed
unfortunately this algorithm requires
logarithmically many iterations or
recursions
and each of these sort of rounds
would require logarithmically many bits
and this would
bring us back to a log square and space
algorithm which we
all kind of already know exists just
above the statistical threshold
finally there's an algorithm by dekel
guril gurewicz and perez from
2014 that also does something like the
factor on algorithm
where it maintains a set of vertices
and improves the ratio of
click to non-click vertices in every
round
unfortunately this algorithm uses
randomness
and also depends on the
edge structure of the input a lot
and so again it's not really clear how
to implement the space efficiently
it seems like we might need some new
ideas to
to do something here having said that
one of the new ideas will be
trying to see how to de-randomize the
dgp-14 algorithm
although we won't get into the technical
details today
and so i'll just tell you about what our
main result is
the main result is that we come very
close to our desired goal but not
quite exactly where we want to be
we can you can create a recovery
algorithm that solves the
problem for k larger than root n in this
ugly looking space complexity bound
the log star function is simply
the number of times you need to
the the height of the power tower you
require
to reach n so
for example the log star of 2 to the 2
to the 2 to the 2
would be 3 or was it 4.
anyway you get the idea it's very very
very
small let's look at two cases to
understand it better
suppose k is little omega square root n
times log
l n where if l is say
3 then it's square root 10 log log log n
and basically l could be any constant
integer
and the space complexity of this
algorithm that we design
would be over log n that's good
if k is theta of root n though the space
usage would actually be log star n
times log n widths and so what this is
showing is that
while we come very close to the desired
space complexity bound we don't actually
reach there however this just
this does suggest that the desired log
space algorithm exists
and this suggests that the statistical
computational phenomena that
hold for time complexity also hold for
the space complexity of this problem
i'll end by mentioning a couple of open
problems
the first is the obvious open problem
which is is there a log space algorithm
that requires planet leaks of size omega
of root n
and the second more vague and open-ended
open problem is
is there a more generic way to study
these gaps
for large classes of problems here we've
taken
one problem one alternate notion of
complexity
studied it but it might get annoying to
have to do this for all the problems for
which we have statistical computation
gaps
so is there a more generic way of trying
to do this
and that is the end of my
end of my time here thanks for listening
and
thank you